[Music]
i'm sorry newt
you don't have to be sorry it wasn't
your fault that's it man game over man
it's game over what are we gonna do now
what are we gonna do maybe we could
build a fire sing a couple of songs huh
why don't we try that we better get back
because it'll be dark soon and they
mostly come at night
mostly
ever since 1979 when ridley scott
blasted the haunted house formula into
deep space the alien franchise has been
synonymous with brooding atmosphere
strong female leads and films that just
overall ooze with style along with
whatever else that drips out of a
xenomorph's mouth
[Music]
its out of this world rival came with
the release of the predator franchise
expanding the universe with its own
series of grotesquely magnificent movies
that have equally carved their name in
the space horror genre
[Music]
for this list we are covering the
hunters the hunted and pretty much every
spin-off in between let's see how all of
them stack together as we rank all alien
and predator movies by tomato meter
[Music]
starting with number 10 alien vs
predator
when the wealthy and ambitious charles
bishop weyland funds an expedition to
antarctica he hopes to find him a
serious source of heat that has been
detected led by a tough guide alexa
woods weyland and his team uncover a
pyramid but they also find malevolent
parasitic aliens making matters worse
another extraterrestrial species known
as predators arrived to hunt the other
aliens with the humans caught in the
middle of the conflict starring saina
lathan raul bova lance henriksen and
directed by paul w s anderson critics
say gore with outscares and cardboard
cutout characters make this clash of the
monsters a dull sit
uh
[Music]
so
number nine the predator
from the outer reaches of space to the
small town streets of suburbia the hunt
comes home the universe's most lethal
hunters are stronger smarter and
deadlier than ever before having
genetically upgraded themselves with dna
from other species when a boy
accidentally triggers their return to
earth only a ragtag group of ex-soldiers
and an evolutionary biologist can
prevent the end of the human race
starring boyd holbrook travante rhodes
jacob tremblay and directed by shane
black critics say the predator has
violence and quips to spare but it's
chaotically hollow action adds up to
another missed opportunity for a
franchise increasingly defined by
disappointment found his escape pod in
mexico still looking for the ship he
came in
he's heavily sedated
you are one beautiful mother
i'm gonna guess your second question is
why are you here
our test results yielded something a
little
odd
is this a joke
we ran the genome sequence 10 times
this specimen has human dna yeah yeah
look we know about spontaneous
speciation mostly plants and insects but
but some mammals sheep goats uh the red
wolf is known to be a hybrid between the
coyote and the grave possibly some form
of recombinant technology
guys guys i get it i get it
you want to know someone an alien
yeah
number eight alien three
ellen ripley is the only survivor when
she crash lands on fiorina 161 a bleak
wasteland inhabited by former inmates of
the planet's maximum security prison
once again ripley must face skepticism
and the alien as it hunts down the
prisoners and guards without weapons or
modern technology of any kind ripley
leads the men into battle against the
terrifying creature starring sigourney
weaver charles s dutton charles dance
and directed by david fincher critics
say alien 3 takes admirable risks with
franchise mythology but far too few pay
off in a thinly scripted sequel whose
stylish visuals aren't enough to enliven
a lack of genuine thrills
what about you i'm staying here
there's gonna be ten tons of hot in here
i'm telling you i wanna die we gotta
deal
remember it dies first then you i'm not
gonna move without you now get going
i've gotta hold it here what about me
god will take care of you now sister
[Music]
number seven alien resurrection
200 years have passed since ellen ripley
died on fiorina 161 aboard the medical
research vessel usm auriga a team of
scientists cloned ripley from her
extracted dna and removes the alien
queen embryo which was growing inside
her at the time of her death starring
sigourney weaver winona ryder ron
perlman and directed by jean-pierre
janette critics say alien resurrection
marks a slight improvement over its
predecessor but it still lacks the
emotional stakes that help make the
franchise's first two entries sci-fi
horror classics
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
time
[Music]
[Music]
number six alien covenant
bound for a remote planet on the far
side of the galaxy members of the colony
ship covenant discover what they think
to be an uncharted paradise while there
they meet david the synthetic survivor
of the doom prometheus expedition the
mysterious world soon turns dark and
dangerous when a hostile alien life form
forces the crew into a deadly fight for
survival starring michael fassbender
catherine waterston billy crudup and
directed by ridley scott critics say
alien covenant delivers another
satisfying round of close quarters deep
space terror even if it doesn't take the
saga in any new directions
so
move
don't shoot
don't shoot
communication captain
breathe on the nostrils of alls and
he'll be yours for life
but you have to get close
you have to earn its respect
[Applause]
oh good deal
it trusted me
number five predators
brought together on a mysterious planet
a mercenary and a group of cold-blooded
killers now become the prey a new breed
of aliens pursues the ragtag humans
through dense jungle and the group must
work together to survive or become the
latest trophies of the fearsome
intergalactic hunters starring adrian
brody topher grace alice braga and
directed by nimrod and tall critics say
after a string of subpar sequels this
bloody action-packed reboot takes the
predator franchise back to its
testosterone-fueled roots
[Music]
so
peace
me
[Music]
number four prometheus
the discovery of a clue to mankind's
origins on earth leads a team of
explorers to the darkest parts of the
universe two brilliant young scientists
lead the expedition shaw hopes that they
will meet a race of benevolent godlike
beings who will in some way verify her
religious beliefs while holloway is out
to debunk any spiritual notions however
neither the scientists nor their
shipmates are prepared for the
unimaginable terrors that await them
starring numi ripass michael fassbender
charlize sarin and directed by ridley
scott critics say ridley scott's
ambitious quasi prequel to alien may not
answer all of its big questions but it's
redeemed by its haunting visual grandeur
and compelling performances particularly
michael fassbender as a fastidious
android
[Music]
elizabeth are you there
this is david
yeah
yeah i'm here you need to get out
immediately
he's coming for you
who's coming airlock breach
[Music]
bye
huh
number three predator
dutch a soldier of fortune is hired by
the us government to secretly rescue a
group of politicians trapped in
guatemala but when dutch and his team
which includes weapons expert blaine and
cia agent george land in central america
something is gravely wrong after finding
a string of dead bodies the crew
discovers they're being hunted by a
brutal creature with superhuman strength
and the ability to disappear into its
surroundings starring arnold
schwarzenegger carl weathers jesse
ventura and directed by john mctiernan
critics say predator part sci-fi part
horror part action all muscle
[Music]
[Music]
number two aliens
after floating in space for 57 years
lieutenant ripley shuttle is found by a
deep space salvage team upon arriving at
lv 426 the marines find only one
survivor a nine-year-old girl named newt
but even these battle-hardened marines
with all the latest weaponry are no
match for the hundreds of aliens that
have invaded the colony starring
sigourney weaver carrie hen michael bean
and directed by james cameron critics
say while alien was a marvel of slow
building atmospheric tension aliens
packs a much more visceral punch and
features a typical strong performance
from sigourney weaver
[Music]
come on let's move
we are leaving
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
forget him he's gone
and finally number one alien
in deep space the crew of the commercial
starship nostromo is awakened from their
cryosleep capsules halfway through their
journey home to investigate a distress
call from an alien vessel the terror
begins when the crew encounters a nest
of eggs inside the alien ship an
organism from inside an egg leaps out
and attaches itself to one of the crew
causing him to fall into a coma starring
sigourney weaver tom skerritt john hurt
and directed by ridley scott critics say
a modern classic alien blend science
fiction horror and bleak poetry into a
seamless hole
okay
[Music]
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time i'm your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you